ladies and gentlemen welcome to the tim
dillon show we do apologize that it is
late we are how how many days later we
uh three days four days it'll be four
four days late
uh
it's not our fault for the free well is
it not
there's a mandate here we had to go find
our vax cards we're in l.a we were not i
don't let anyone record
unless they have been
vaccinated and boosted twice yeah which
is not even required or allowed i tried
to sneak some ivermectin in here and rub
it on myself but you stopped it you
confiscated it and you said only vaxxed
only
boosted
double masked
face shield
over every orifice we must prolong life
at all costs yeah
no matter what we must defeat covet no
matter what prior infection you gave me
cobit so i could recover so i could come
in here we will defeat covid yes not the
chinese but covered we will we will beat
it we will beat it with our antibodies
which are just tiny little mini rogans
that call in your body and fight back
yes thank god
well i'll tell you this i had a birthday
giannis pappas is with us
i had a birthday recently am i at the
point where i'm friend of the show yet
yeah friend of the show
of the show i like that that means like
um you know i'm friends with you guys
friend of the show yeah
and i had a birthday recently and uh
it's a real when you get older and you
have birthdays you realize
they number one they
they're annoying
and they shouldn't be celebrated and
then you you realize your friends are
like my friend michael who's a nice guy
he's i'm the godfather to his son who i
love but he's like an idiot and he
ordered
like italian subs to my room
in new york city and like a chicouteri
platter and like a tray of like chicken
parmesan
and this is after louie anderson and
meatloaf both dropped dead
and he decided to order this
in my room i'm staying there in new york
cologne and then i'm not there i'm doing
stuff the whole day i come back it's
just cold food
that this junkie
has sent to my room
and i hate i hate the calls and the
texts happy birthday from people you
haven't spoken to in years yeah well
that's how you know i'm a real friend
yes first of all i don't even think you
called or texted if i would have known
it was your birthday yeah i was about i
was about to say this is how you know
i'm a real friend then i realized i
didn't know it was your birthday no but
that's a friend that's a friend yeah
people that go oh it's
people are texting you and speaking you
haven't spoken to them in years
happy birthday boss yeah
what
yeah that's embarrassing well you know
i'm you know if someone's gonna if if
someone in this business is gonna wish
you a happy birthday this is what i
learned this week yeah if i'm gonna wish
tim dillon a happy birthday
i'm gonna plug my dates at the end i'm
gonna turn that camera around bert
christopher gave me a nice one-two
lesson on turning it into content i'm
like happy birthday tim dillon he's the
best marketer in the business you swing
that cat he does the swing yeah and you
go tampa february 10th yeah so joel's
yeah february best market no if his
daughter is a period he goes on
instagram live
he's the best
marketer in the entire business it
should be
it should be you should listen to that
yeah
yeah that is the goal yeah
ben gets a happy birthday text because i
i can't monetize it yeah so you'll get
one but for timmy dillon i'm yeah i'm
shooting a sketch with it yeah it's got
to be it's got to mean more yeah but you
just get you get older and and you
realize that you're just dying and then
the people that are wishing you happy
birthday in a weird way or they kind of
want you to die yeah
i almost feel like every text like happy
birthday hope it's the last one
you know yeah well it's almost like a
message when you send those type of
sandwiches to the room
that it was it was embarrassing that's
how you know my friend i would have sent
you if i would have known it was your
birthday i would have given you what you
want what you need and that's a pokeball
yeah i mean you it's embarrassing to
come back to like chafing dishes from a
long island
fireman's retirement party yeah in your
room alone yeah i'm like this is an
embarrassing thing that nobody needs
and i'm in bed now i gotta call the
people at hotel can you just take this
out
can you take all this food out of here
did you not eat it and just order it
cold yeah it's it's been sitting there
for 10 hours so what you're saying is
it's not always the thought that counts
it's never the thought that counts it's
a lie
but when
when when michelle our friend michelle
brought you brought you a re-gifted
sweater that was three sizes too small
wasn't that that was a good thought she
she she she bought a gift for someone
that didn't want it
and then she came in and gave it to me
and it was three sizes too small
thoughtful though thoughtful yeah yeah
thoughtful as if she walked past it in
her house and said oh i got to get rid
of she's the type of person when she
lies
she believes it yeah so that's the best
type of liar right she believed as soon
as that person said i don't want this
michelle literally believed that she
bought it for me
yeah she believes it that's how you know
faith is stronger than reason yeah
because if she would have taken one
second to reason she would have said tim
is not a child small
yeah it was cr and then she said
something like yeah you you work in i go
you work she goes yeah she goes you jog
and you'll fit in this yeah yeah jog
yeah
i'll jog and get hit by a bus and
reincarnated as someone who still
wouldn't fit
into it it was but she's a lot but i
like people around me that are liars and
degenerates it's a good show it's a fun
show it's a fun show no most of my
friends are you know they're
these are people you want to watch yeah
yeah we just had them for two reasons
double entendre yes pun intended we just
had a fun meeting yeah we had a fun
meeting and i don't know if we should
talk about this
should we she text your lawyer first we
had a fun meeting with the people that
run the sub stack
so have you heard of this now
subset journalists
can't get things published in the
mainstream news
um
when they're writing because the
mainstream news we all know
is corporate sponsored
propaganda
and
these people are fearless thought
leaders
yeah
yes they are
yes they are so
they're fearless thought leaders
and
which i like i'm all for substance go
make that money hey go make that bread
barry
who came to the show we had a great show
at the comedy store kevin hart chris
rock uh
and then barry weiss came to the show
and did uh i did 30 minutes uh talked
about uh uh israel
at the end we appreciated that
uh we had a meeting with the sub stack
founder wanted to meet with me
and i brought you yes
it's much like in good will hunting
when matt damon just sent ben affleck
but he didn't want it yeah i went in
there like ben affleck like
retainer well they
they called me and ben right yes yes and
it described for the people what they're
trying to do because the show on patreon
is big and they want us to jump they
want us to jump over from patreon to
them and take everything with with us
and get off and get off youtube yes for
free for free
and get off youtube as well for no money
cause you're friends because we believe
in what they're doing
so they call us a woman called us and
she's a nice woman she's a peppy
she's a pep
and she called hi
hi
we're like big fans
i
i'm like 20 million bucks
20 million dollars i mean you saw her
address she could afford it 20 no she
can't
20 million dollars
like i said if you give me 20 million
i'll youtube i'll say youtube i'm off
sorry susan whatever name is i leave
here and then i leave the patreon i
don't know who the hell runs at
20 million but because we got businesses
that make money
rogan got a lot but you got to pay money
here
and so then we threw that number out and
then she you could tell she was like
aghast at that number on the phone she
didn't understand it maybe she thought
you were joking that's why they went
through at the meeting yeah so i don't
know what she thought but then she said
we want you should sit down
with the founder of
sub stack
because they want to be doing more stuff
with content so i brought you you
brought me yeah you you brought me in it
was a message you were basically saying
me and my friend were walking and we may
walk by that restaurant we're having fun
you're not in l.a all the time no
this is not a serious signing meeting i
can tell that yeah the message is uh i'm
gonna fit you into what i'm doing yeah
yeah we're gonna and and and how do you
think it went did you enjoy it it was a
as we said it was a good show
it was fun it was a good show you
you
set the game at the beginning yeah they
they thought hey we're gonna sit down
they were thinking like this is gonna be
a three-hour meal we're gonna get to
know tim and only tim yeah the
reservation was for four right we had to
change tables they were like oh who's
this yeah and tim's like this is my
friend we had to find a new table they
had to put us in another section of the
restaurant yeah and they thought it was
just gonna be a nice bonding
dinner
where
you were an ally in the revolution right
yeah they didn't know that you were
there to let them know we're playing a
different game and that game is
listen let's get right to it
because let's not act like we all don't
have real friends yeah i mean let's say
that let's get back to our real friends
we we have real friends they said let's
we all have real friends yeah and you
know we're like
let's not get right to it yes cut it out
yeah yeah let's cut it out here we all
got real friends waiting for us are you
smoking crack
uh we're not moving the operation
to sub stack
for no money
[Music]
are you on
crack cocaine
sir
good sir
and madam
they said to me they go we'd love if you
did it for a reason it was other than
financial
what
no
i well i'm not gonna do it
the only reason i would do it
if you gave me a shitload of money and i
don't have to charge anybody any more
money on patreon meaning like
my fans get the same deal they've always
had they don't get [ __ ] over at all
and you give me a chunk of money
then maybe we'll consider it
but you didn't want to just
my the thing that i was a little
surprised by was that you didn't want to
get to know them better they they seemed
like it would be a fun hank yeah they
wanted yeah they wanted to like be
buddies
they thought we were going to be buds
and they thought it was going to work
out where i would be like hey you know
it would be fun
i was going to call ben and go let's
just just just delete the patreon right
now
they thought i was gonna do in the
middle of dinner i go hey why don't we
delete let's just delete the uh youtube
and the patreon yeah i you know you guys
are visionaries and i just want to do it
for the culture the cause yeah i'm
excited i'm excited about it and
that's why i worked so hard to build it
on my own just so i could just over
dinner i could be charmed and give it
away yeah and they go they go we don't
want to own you yeah
i go
well i'm not owned now right nobody owns
me now
they're like well what's great about the
sub stack is we have the email
yeah
they go we have the email list have you
you have we have email on the site we
can email the people they know we have
that too right i don't know if they do
know that we have email they go we have
email you can email your people when
their episodes come out you send the
email they were really searching for
reasons why they didn't know what they
didn't know they had no idea they had no
idea what the advantage would be they go
well it's a community yeah
it's a community of people that get
emails yeah
don't you want and i said i like what
you're doing i like the idea that these
journalists can go make money
andrew sullivan and barry weiss and uh
greenwald and taibi whoever these are
people that should have a platform and a
way to monetize uh their stuff but then
they were like [ __ ] on patreon and
it's like listen
you're just doing what patreon did
for journalists that's exactly what it
is that's what it is yeah you're
cheating on the thing that you that
that's the whole thing right right it
would almost be like if patreon met with
the journalists right and said hey guys
why don't you come over here for nothing
and then right be like wouldn't that
disrupt my whole thing right and they go
no no no no no no no because we have
emails yeah what about the email
signatures have you heard of the email
we we can send emails to people here you
don't have to go to the post office
anymore yeah
it's not snail mail we got real email we
got the real thing we got real email
here yeah and uh they were nice enough
people but they didn't i don't i don't
think they fully understood
what
they were saying
no yeah like i said they were calling
for a different type of meeting
the meeting they had was a lot shorter
than they expected
was i rude no i don't think you were
rude i was cold
i think i think you were realistic i
think it was well the restaurant's
disgusting yeah well that part brought
me to a dump then you admitted you'd
never been there before why would you
take me someplace you've never been
these tech people don't eat they don't
know anything about food right um
and they brought me to some dump right
and and then it was just kind of a
contentious back and forth and then well
i stood up and left yeah right in the
middle of one of their sentences yeah
yeah you went oh i forgot i have to do
this thing and that was it and there was
yeah
one of the guys his face was just turned
red a lot right it looked like he was it
looked like he was on a date with a
crush and he just kept turning red
from
his
expectation that things would have been
different and they were not what he
thought well it it's kind of wild to me
to imagine that somebody would disrupt
their entire thing to go over to this
other thing that has value i'm sure i
mean people make money there
for nothing
yeah
what are we talking about yeah that's
that's exactly how elon musk got started
i want all of the money you're giving to
katie herzog i want it now
that's exactly how all the big guys got
started they built the thing and then
someone came and said do it over here
just do it here make us big it's
i'd like one the guy goes i'd like you
to be jazzed about it
are you jazzed
i go no you're you're not saying there's
no money yeah
yeah and then one guy goes well why is
it so much money i go will you give me
three times what i'm making minimum yeah
because why change anything it's not
broke don't fix who cares right now if
the guy wasn't foreign from a country
that you
australia i got problems with them and
why
i said during the quarantine lockdown
that australians were lazy criminals who
wanted to drink in their backyards and
didn't value having any kind of rights
including the right to work which in
australia is laughable it's like america
the right to exercise right you know
australia the right to work it's like
nobody
i mean it's just it's not even real
there okay there's a few people in
australia that work very few
uh but the vast majority of people who
live in australia are wombats
there's nothing wrong with that but
they're you know what i mean yeah
they're like doing chewies they're
drinking beer out of their shoe
they're animals
are we you know and i get death threats
all the time about this and then they
want me to go tour there to get killed
really australians get really that bent
out of shame some of them get mad they
can't take a joke yeah and the other
problem is i'm not joking
so then that's the problem right but
this guy was fun enough the australian
guy he was trying he was trying he was
trying yeah he was really trying he was
trying he reminded me of like a girl
who's been kidnapped yeah
and
she's seen the face of the guy that's
kidnapped her and she's pleading just
please i want to see my parents please
let let me live and the guy goes of
course i'm gonna let you live if you're
just good and do what i say right and
then
in the back of her head she has a little
hope and she keeps you know and then she
knows she when she turns around he's
just gonna hit her in the head with a
brick yeah to kill the witness
yeah the vibe was like a little glimmer
of hope even just out of desperation
you said substance they're having
problems right now what's going on with
they got the q and on people in there
now yeah i'll pull this up they've david
i saw that on right wing watch today ugh
don't bring up right wing watch i hate
them
i hate anyone that's watching anyone
stop watching
left wing why any of the watches
why anti-vaxxers q anon influencers and
white nationalists are flocking to
sub-stack
well this is gonna be silly
let's i mean
what are they mad about here robert
malone and baron said let him say what
they want to say
who are the q and on influencers i'm
more interested in that i'm bored of
this vaccine nonsense you got to admit
the q9 guys got better imaginations if
you're still in q anon right now it's
nothing short of downright impressive it
is it is commitment the fact that you've
been queuing on is like guys at the in
during the mortgage crisis they're like
no it's still good
it's still good yeah
yeah my favorite was when they were
showing up in dallas
at daley plaza
waiting for jfk junior to come back i
mean that is beauty they're having more
fun on earth than we will ever have
um
you got to admit it's fun it's a fun
club it's it's absolutely fun it's a lot
more fun than the other side who's just
going around you've got to be in a club
yeah so whether you get an ape nft and
change your profile picture and then
you're in the that board 8 got club yeah
or you go to daley plaza and wait for
jfk junior to come back the latter
sounds a lot funner to me some guy
mercola is open about the fact that he's
using sub stack to publish content which
even he himself considered to be too
controversial to keep on his own website
in may 2021 he deleted posts on a site
which promoted a range of false cover 19
cures including effectively inhaling
bleach
i look kind of like that in his substack
post mercola announcing he'll be
bringing his deleted content back by
publishing it on the platform that is
kind of funny hey all that content i got
rid of it's back baby i love that his
cure is the same as an alcohol desperate
alcoholic who's ran out of real bottles
right just just start huffing
just start looking that's what
alcoholics do when they're out they just
start looking under the sink but here's
the deal
people this is a subscriber model you
subscribe
what's the problem adults subscribing
for the entertainment they want this
isn't a super bowl commercial no we're
not going in the middle of super bowl
standing hail bleach yeah covered hey
right wing watch if you haven't noticed
this is a private club it's a private
club people pay to get in why you can't
it's just like any private club right
you're on someone's property right now
how about you go after the bohemian
grove or like skull and balt like what
about those they're private clubs yes
q and on influencers uh
are on sub stack
jordan sather patel patriot and
technofrog
techno fog technology technofog post
regularly for both free and paid
subscribers
while in the comments q and followers
engage with one another to debate and
share conspiracy well where would you
where do you want them to do it right
where do you want them to do it
that could have been an effective pitch
if they did it much better if they said
hey tim yes you know
you joke about everybody yes you're a
comedian
but if you ever wan lose it right if you
ever lose it right and go hard right
we got your back no it would be better
if they sat me down and said there's
it's a matter of time before you
degenerate
it's a matter of time before you turn
that corner right we want to let you
know we are that cool it's a safe place
for you we are will allow you to go rant
and rave about whatever you think
the problem is that week yeah
whatever scrambled brain
you have
in the future it has a home it has a
home it's just on sub
yes that at least would have been a
pitch it would have been something it
would have been smart yeah
i don't even want to go into all the
names of the people i don't care they've
named a ton of people
it doesn't matter to me because i i i
don't if you're subscribing
who gives a [ __ ] right but
isn't it a hip place for a comedian to
be in a club with a bunch of classical
liberal journalists
that's the other thing i mean that's as
hip as it gets there's no comedians over
there no and if they want a comedian to
come over there they gotta
you know
give me a lot of money money
that's all we're talking about yeah
that's the difference between comedians
and journalists comedians have the
potential and often do make real money
right yeah what i should have said is
yes i'll do it for free yes but my show
is me and alex jones
let me tell you who my show is before
i'm gonna do it for free they would have
smiled and been excited i would have
said
you got me yeah i hey yeah you're right
yeah i don't need any money to delete
the youtube channel in the patreon can
you imagine these psychopaths yeah we'll
delete it all and we'll build it back
from scratch so it's me and alex jones
you go there you go we want the tim
dylan joe you go you know what i don't
want to do the tim dolce tim dillon
show's dead i want to do crisis actors
yeah tim dillon and alex jones i have a
new show called sandy hook question mark
where mean alex jones go over the
evidence because there's evidence
there's not but i would say that at the
dinner because there's evidence no i've
seen some auditions in backstage
magazine for crisis yes i've seen it
yeah i've seen it people that want to
pretend they got shot yeah outside of
school yeah but it didn't work and we
laughed and unfortunately i think the
door is now going to be shut
after this show that's so strange
because at the end you said let's keep
talking
let's keep talking yeah i'm talking now
yes i think that's what you meant yeah
we're all talking you're like i'll be
talking later
yeah yeah we're gonna talk yeah
it was fun
one of them said
he thinks he could come up with
something that you might be interested
in i remember that yeah yeah what a
commemorative mug
they added in mines
a tote bag
bag what would the point be this is the
thing
now people are probably listening to
this going you greedy pig all you want
is money yeah okay that's number one
what else would be the point yeah what's
the point friendship right
[Laughter]
they go no you have all your content in
one place yeah you've got it in youtube
and on patreon and oh it's all over they
were basically saying like don't you
want to hide it all yeah you know how
everything's decentralized what if you
centralize it all yeah you know how it's
so accessible on every platform yeah
what if we hit it on ours what if we
hide it and put it somewhere yeah
yeah that's basically and this new thing
which i didn't realize every subscriber
that signed up would have to be
interviewed by barry weiss
whether they were anti-semitic or not
they threw that in at the end there's a
test barry weiss gives every new
subscriber she calls you on the phone
and and goes through 10 questions if
you're anti-semitic
i love box of awesome they've advertised
for 40 [ __ ] years
on this show
because it's a box of stuff that's fun
to open it's always different it has 70
worth of gear in it but it only cost you
45. you subscribe you is someone going
away to college what a gift
mail grooming and shaving and outdoorsy
stuff what are what are the people into
that you're getting this for because if
somebody moves to a new city it's a box
they can get every [ __ ] month
that's what they get
oh it's another gift it's another gift
it's a you don't even have to call your
child just get them this they'll call
you every month thanks what came in the
box oh they gave me a
a knife this time well
you better keep it because you know how
it's getting where you chose to live dad
don't say that you can't say that i'm
just saying there's problems there dad
it's not as bad as the news is making it
seem i'm saying it's heading in a bad
direction i'm not gonna live with you
and mom in the suburbs you drunk
i'm just saying you better keep that
knife you won great
box of awesome
they have collections for every part of
your life to get started take the quiz
at box of awesome.com your answers will
help them pick the right box of awesome
for you they release new boxes every
month across a ton of different
categories it's free to sign up and you
can skip a month or cancel any time each
box costs only forty five dollars and
it's seventy dollars worth of stuff plus
each box of awesome you're supporting
small business 90 of everything that
comes in your box of awesome is from a
small up-and-coming brand
get 20 off your first monthly box when
you sign up box of awesome.com and enter
the code tim dillon at checkout that's
box of awesome.com code tim dillon for
20 off your first box
i love box of awesome for the winter
because i was given a hatchet
headphones
a mitten a pipe
uh a bird's wing it's like a game of
clue
i got a den candle
cedar spills and cigar cutter reclaimed
wood ash train candle holder and cigars
nice
oh man i love it i got a knife i love it
i enjoy it it's fun
everybody's having problems better help
atlp is the move it's online
professional
great thing it's professional counseling
done securely there's a broad range of
expertise available which may not be
locally available in many areas
the service is available for clients
worldwide you can log into your account
anytime send a message to your counselor
you'll get timely and thoughtful
responses plus you can schedule weekly
or video
phone sessions you won't be able to have
you won't be able to see you won't ever
have to sit in an uncomfortable waiting
room as with traditional therapy right
giannis right i've used it yeah
betterhelp is committed to facilitating
great therapeutic matches so they make
it easy and free to change counselors if
needed
it's more affordable than traditional
offline counseling and financial aid is
available
betterhelp wants you to start living a
better happier life today
the podcast is sponsored by better help
tim dillon show listeners get 10 off
their first month at betterhelp.comd
start living a happier life today visit
their website and read the testimonials
that are posted daily betterhelp.com tim
d that's better atlp and join over a
million people who've taken charge of
their mental health with the help of an
experienced professional accessible all
the time
bitcoin down right now people are upset
cryptos tumbling the true believers are
doubling down maybe some of them are
buying nobody knows where the bottom is
or the floor
you were just talking about odell
beckham jr yeah he took his whole salary
for the rams 1 million bucks in bitcoin
full in bitcoin someone ran the numbers
all he all his payouts to agents lawyers
whatever with the dip in bitcoin it's
now worth
34 000 is what he's making right now
playing for the rams as a professional
football player
yeah
but it could go up right
that is true so that's why you do the
bitcoin that is the hope yeah i'm not
getting into it until there's a way i
can hold it
i need well that's the whole but that's
the whole point is you can't i know but
they got at least an effigy at least
some symbol of it to know that it's in
the computer so if i go to a strip club
yeah i can i need to be able to throw it
i need to be able to fling it as a
stripper yeah i can't just add like
strippers hanukkah coins yeah i just
can't tell the stripper like do you want
to be a part of the future or not
strippers are taking crypto are they why
not
i don't know maybe not this week
yeah it's tough it's down about 37 000.
what's the lowest it hit
the lowest uh this year
well the lowest hit in the past couple
of weeks uh it looks like about 36.
it's um
i have one bitcoin so i just watch my
bitcoin
go up and then go down
hopefully we're going back to the
bitcoin conference again this year in
april
we're we're negotiating that
yeah we have sub stack who's going to
negotiate it for us so we're really
excited about what they get
well like does having a bitcoin if you
have a bitcoin does madagascar get to
have electricity like is there a way to
do it where everyone can still keep
electricity
because it takes a lot of energy right
it doesn't take as much energy as other
things no i mean it takes a lot of
energy the mining of it right but i mean
everything takes energy right so i mean
we hop on a plane whenever the hell we
want is it does it take as much energy
as trying to decipher a text from
whitney cummings nothing takes that much
energy so then does whitney have any
bitcoin
i don't know i stayed at her house i
think she thought it was shultz for the
first two days she pissed on uh on the
lawn she pissed it along like a dog now
why does she use the bathroom outside
she does that because she wants to mark
the ground
her her what she owns so the coyotes
know that another animal is there and
the territory's claimed and she's right
there is an animal there
well
there is an animal
there is an untrained animal
no yeah she got up from supper we were
eating yeah she took the dog out she's
got a baby little pit
and to show the baby she was teaching
the baby she squatted and peed and then
the baby and the baby who's gonna pee
anyway yeah but in her mind she's going
the baby's now peeing the baby pitbull
is not peeing because i showed it to pee
right nobody does that th the pipple's
still gonna pee cause dogs pee when they
gotta go to the bathroom they don't pee
because they watched a human do it
outside and then go okay now you gave me
that idea this is the real q anon it's
not it's people think it's these
hollywood sex parties it's just whitney
coming [ __ ] on her lawn yes no like
now that i've been here a week and
nobody's drinking baby blood but people
are [ __ ] on their own property
outside yeah yeah i mean we love her and
she's a wild woman yes you know and
she's unpredictable and i went to
stamos's house i checked the basement
yeah there's no adrenochrome bar i don't
think he was ever implicated well he's
close enough to tom hanks that's true
right so even if he's not doing it he
knows about it tom yeah that was a big
one tom hanks was the big one right
right i just i checked there's no
chrissy teigen is where i tapped out
yeah cause like why she's not important
i just don't have a high opinion of her
it's like
if you're gonna tell me somebody's uh uh
running a human trafficking ring or
they're satan accountable
at least let them be talented
[Laughter]
you know what i mean like at least let
them have some kind of [ __ ] talent
right like michael jackson i can believe
you know what yeah or you know what i
was thinking about i was thinking about
woody
i was in new york and i was thinking
about woody i drove by
where he lives i was staying up there in
that area in the upper east side and
i mean the guy is just such a chronic
the the way he chronicled
manhattan and new york in a place that
we love
um
is you know he's on his 50th
feature
the man is 86. and he's gonna have to
sell it on louis ck's website he's
selling
[Music]
his new movie is coming out on
gasdigital.com
yes digitalnetwork.com who is jay gomez
woody allen's new podcast at cass
digital with zac amico
what do you feel about because
here's the the way we come down on it
is he guilty probably is mia guilty yes
put them all in jail
she adopted an entire taiwanese [ __ ]
village you got to cut her off at some
point like a bartender at a bar you've
had too many
she's bringing thailand to him
[Laughter]
he doesn't even have to get on a plane
so like my whole thing is like uh is
everybody has some blame there and i
don't want to make light of this this
young girl suffering
if this happened right which it might
have
and i you know
but how do you as a new yorker it's a
tough one and a fan of woody allen
and someone who has a daughter and cares
about kids
how do you make everything okay in your
head because this is the thing now
that's coming up in a lot of
discussions we are finding out that most
of these or not most but a good amount
of these people that we held in high
esteem and respected
uh cooked children in a pot
the only way you could do it is by
separating the art from the artist like
taking away his movies from us
isn't a punishment to him it's a
punishment to us
so right give us the movies because the
movies are good the movies didn't diddle
anyone the movies did nothing wrong put
woody
and all turn epstein island which is now
vacant i'm sure somebody's trying to buy
it probably the chinese yeah but before
the chinese bitcoin 2022 little st james
take that island and make it a metoo
island yes and you put all because a lot
of talented guys have been me tood think
about the lineup at a comedy club great
idea if you did a me too tour great idea
i mean you got cosby closing you got
louie yeah you got uh is i don't know is
delia back he's back he's back i don't
know what he did maybe he didn't do it
he didn't but he was opening that you're
opening with a bang yeah you're open
with the bank and then you have woody
making movies you got louie making his
movie too which is the brothers mcmullen
with joe list right you got it all
cooking and and you and you stream it to
us we get to see it but they have to
live horribly like they're in jail but
on a tropical island on a tropical
island it's a it's a jail they're
they're white-collar criminals you can't
put them in rikers you know it's gonna
hurt their creativity they need
cantaloupe they need cantaloupe right
and they need the occasional thing that
they like but what happens when you take
all these uh people that have massive
problems you purge all of them from art
do you know what you get
you and i'm not saying art should be
created by exclusively pedophiles right
but i'm saying that like when you get
rid of all of the people that have ever
said a wrong thing or had a bad
relationship been a drug addict what are
you gonna get you get bad art you get
bad art you get homogenous boring
pointless horseshit that nobody likes it
doesn't it it's it doesn't resonate with
anybody
the people that don't understand the
human condition
um you get like weird paper pusher
uh office politics type of like
bureaucrats that are now
trying to be comedians and artists and
movie filmmakers it's weird we suffer
there's no reason for us to suffer right
and we the taxpayers should be able to
say we demand their art but they can't
get paid for it what if there was just a
disclaimer before the movie go this
movie's made by a pedophile yeah i think
adult i think yeah would you even leave
the theater if they said this movie is
made by a pedophile how many people
leave the theater what if it was a big
one like a new marvel movie right before
it they just come out with a screen to
go ah this movie's made by a pedophile
i'm a mature adult i get it yeah you go
you go hey separate not into that yeah
not into that but let's check out what
these are people would scream that at
the screen maybe some guy separate the
odds from the artist like somebody was
gonna walk out and he'd be like but you
gotta separate diode
from the artist
it's the only way to do it we should not
suffer yeah i mean the guy who made the
galaxy movie he he had some
some she had some tweets some tweets
some jokes james
yeah
so i mean don't take him away he makes
good movies he doesn't
yeah i mean like
it's a real sticky thing yeah because we
obviously view
the activities is vile and heinous
with woody
you know
it's it's weird because it's in the
context of a family
dynamic that was really [ __ ]
him and me had this weird
it's unfair can we trade
like because
woody's hearsay right it's like her
story versus his right shoes but also
hers and like some of the friends some
more yeah okay there's a few words it's
hers and hers and hers versus he
probably did it he might have but even
like dalia it's just hearsay he may not
have done anything it's here it's all
hearsay but that's yours so look about
this trade right we go marv albert the
voice of
the new york knicks and and
national broadcasts on sports forever
retired with grace
after having prostitutes for lunch over
and over again he would bite them and
bite them and bite them and bite he
liked to bite and he got and he just got
grandfathered in to grace
like no consequences can we say hey
we'll give you marv albert we know what
he did we have the bite marks as proof
give us one back
we'll watch him of course
you know we'll make sure he doesn't do
it again but
girls need the leah the comedy fans the
girls they need that he's funny give us
him we'll give you
a real offender i think he's back and i
i think there was a lot of confusion
about what
he did
it's not clear it's not clear
it may be unfair it's not clear yeah
i i i heard he was directed a high
school production of rent
[Laughter]
and people got angry at him now i but i
don't know i don't know we don't know
but no one knows we just know what we
read and how can you trust what you read
i only trust i stack i need have you
gone to sub stack
sub stack is fearless thought leaders i
will work for free
i will not make a decision on what
actually happened to dalia until dr
robert malone comments on it dr robert
malone he'll tell us what's going on
let's get dr robert malone in here
please be like what's the truth about
all these people and what they did he's
got the answers he had like a bolo tie
on when he did
robert malone yeah
nothing instills you with confidence in
a doctor isn't a bolo tie and uh jordan
peterson went into rogue and looking
like huckleberry finn well his pants
were like look like he was in a river
well he's in a he's you know he was in a
um he was in a uh like a uh
uh what was he in like a tux with a bow
tie
and short pants he's like you know it's
not immediately clear to me
why climate
is climate it's not immediately clear to
me
he you know he's been through it yeah
he's been through the ringer he's been
through the ringer and he's a brilliant
guy he's a smart guy yep
and
but he looks right now like he's
uh like he's in his almost his final
form
which is a batman villain like he seems
to be he looks like he just took a break
from a catering hall handing out [ __ ]
shellfish yeah he seems like a like an
angry maitre d at a long island italian
restaurant
screaming about climate change
oh you don't like your table
i told you it's the only table here we
don't have an innumerable amount of
space that's the problem with people
they think there's an innumerable amount
of opportunities to eat you can eat the
eggplant rollatini and you can eat it
anywhere it's not immediately clear to
me if we put you in another table that
you'd be having a better thing the thing
about marxism
and the pareto principle is that that
plant rollatini in any society
concentrates in the hands of fewer and
fewer people well that's correct but
it's actually so correct that you have
no idea how correct it is so it's an
underestimation of the problem your
table on the corner is an
underestimation of the problem
yeah
you just walk away and you go like
rogan needs a new car like rogenstein
has these guys but we got we need
someone new we need who's a new
professor we need like a new
like a new professor yeah yeah because
he's you know he's great but he's he's
you know he's done it right
so we need like a new
yeah who would it be i don't know like
what other professor from some college
you never heard about
yeah it's gotta be it's gotta be from a
small small college that didn't matter
to anyone and they have to be the next
guy yes you know yes
well i'm sure there's a lot the money's
better yeah money's better online than
it is that you know uh
it's got to be like a collet like a
small college yeah
and a video's got to go viral of like uh
a lesbian beating him with a stick yes
like just three lesbians beating him
with a lacrosse stick yeah or just a
bunch of students burning his book yeah
burning his book and they're like
pushing his car like if you see a bunch
of
and we can organize this yeah and
perhaps it has been yeah but you put
someone in a car and then the students
are just like you see the car going back
and forth and the professor's like you
know just a bunch of kids with purple
hair just pouring milkshakes on them as
he screams and then he needs to emerge
as like the next guy yeah
and he's it's got to be a good like the
name has to be perfect yes like it's got
to be like uh the university is always
like uh yeah greenfield yeah greenfield
college yeah greenfield college in
wisconsin dr eric von schlossberg
please welcome dr eric von schlossberg
so you're an anthropologist but let's
talk about microbiology no it'll be a
guy it'll be a guy it'll be a gym team
can it be a gym teacher
it has to be a guy who's who's
who's like
degree is in exercise science
dr eric von schlossberg from uh the
university of winnipeg
brutally beaten by four field dikes
and it is now here to talk about his
theory
of you know of antimatter yeah
why galileo was a hack
dr eric von schlossberg
gym teacher
university of winnipeg let's talk black
holes yeah
yeah no they um
they've really opened up their uh their
fields of interest yeah they really are
well everybody it's the the
like i we always thought about doing a
sketcher it's funny where it's like a
guy who's like has a mentor who's a
professor
and and he sits down with him he's like
i want to let you know thank you so much
for everything you've done for me the
professor's like i'm trying to get on
logan paul's show
are you like working on anything and he
goes yeah i'm working on getting on
impulsive
can you get me on impulsive
yeah and you go well i thought you were
kind of like weren't you working on a
theory yeah yeah i'm working on a theory
of not being broke yeah that's exactly
what it is i got a new theory called not
being broke yes and i'm trying to get my
numbers up yeah and he said a lot of
valuable things and we like jordan we've
had jordan on the show um
you know but it's just it's it's funny
because this is a new archetype of guy
like renegade professor yeah right
renegade professor like back in the day
there were professors who were like
protesting vietnam yes and everybody's
like cute communist piece of [ __ ] but a
lot of them were like legit
protesting a war in vietnam some of you
know chris hedges gave a great speech
during the iraq war and he got booed
where he said this is bad
we shouldn't be doing this
and he was booed and then fired from the
new york times
and i think i forget and ben won't look
it up because he's got too much else on
his plate but i'll just keep spouting
things whether they're true or not chris
hedges uh fired iraq war speech but if
you were at sub stack we give you six
bends yeah yeah that that could have
been another pitch we cloned ben and we
get three more
yeah that's all right we'll get we'll
find it an hour
maybe substance right
oh yeah where was the iraqi commencement
at which college
rockford
illinois illinois but he got fired after
this i think the new york times fired
him
because so professors have always been
speaking out yeah
people speak out all the time about
things but it's not
so so entertainer is that people trying
to get like people that speak out for
like palestinian causes yeah people try
to get them fired a lot yeah you know
yeah that are professors yes so
this happens new york times reporter
chris hedges was booed off the stage and
had his microphone cut twice as he
delivered a graduation speech on war and
empire at rockford college in illinois
it's a ballsy speech right and there you
go another college rockford college
rockford yeah rockford i love bird dogs
they're joggers with a built-in silky
soft inner liner that is the most
comfortable thing you've ever worn
explain why you love your burke because
i do
bird dog joggers are the most
comfortable sweatpants in the world
they're great sweatpants feel the best i
don't care what anyone says
these are sweaty pants you can wear
outside your house and actually look
good sweatpants they're doing it better
than lululemon and actually poach their
head of design [ __ ] you lululemon
you ever do the bird dogs no but i'm
gonna well well you better yeah
bird dogs go to bird dogs that comment
or promo code tim dillon
and they'll throw in a free whistle tip
football so it's fun you know you throw
it around with the kids
that's birddogs.com promo code
tim dillon and boom that's good for dads
in long island who want to try to cure
their kids at gay throw the football out
there see how he catches it absolutely
they're going to edit that out
getting edited out
is this one of them where they added
everything i don't think they'll care i
don't think they'll care
birddogs.com promo code tim dillon and
you get a football so you and your kids
can throw the ball around on the one day
you're legally allowed to see them
birddogs.com it's soft joggy sweatpants
you can wear them
on your couch while you
watch the capitol ride over and over
again
birddogs.com they're fun they're they're
fun and funky they're flexible
they stole lululemon's head of design
enough with this ben you went to another
ad let's do that
i love freshly you know why because it's
a pre-cooked meal
it's not
frozen tasteless or highly processed
i mean we could all benefit from taking
the stress out of cooking i hate people
to cook i wrote a brilliant facebook
status about it years ago people that
cook are soulless
especially in new york city it's all
about going out
people that you know i mean it's
my point is get get what is this freshly
get freshly
why
well
do you have things to do during the day
or night
i do
you know what maybe i do i try to help
the poor
so i don't have time to make a frittata
one time i was so
busy relocating flood victims
that i couldn't eat
and freshly came through in a pinch
and i love it
i had their steak peppercorn
and their masterful mac and cheese and
even plant-based meals
because
i was helping flood victims
find housing also whatever you didn't
eat you hand it out to poor people well
they weren't really hungry they were
more concerned about their homes
skip the grocery shopping and dirty
dishes your meals arrive cooked and
fresh every week new meals are added
weekly so you're never stuck eating the
same thing over and over choose with 50
nutritionist design entries i mean here
is the reality you're a fat slob out
there and the reason you are is because
you don't make the right choices take
the power of choice out of your [ __ ]
life
do it now or you'll fail over and over
again they will give this [ __ ] to you
you just eat it
and it's better than the crap you're
gonna shove in your mouth because you
don't know what's good
and companies spend millions of dollars
on marketing to make you think what
they're giving you is healthy
it's not this is a tiny little fun meal
you get with vegetables you can see and
chew
eat it and that's it when it's done it's
done you don't go back into the fridge
you don't go on post mates
stop stressing about dinner right now
freshly is offering our listeners forty
dollars off your first your orders when
you go to freshly.com tim dillon
that's forty dollars off at
freshly.com slash tim dillon get
delicious made nutrient-packed meals
delivered straight to your door no
cooking required fresh and never frozen
ready to heat and enjoy in just three
minutes
i use freshly where did you you went to
george washington uh no i went to uh the
american university and it's the it's
our yeah it was made by america and
we're in uh in washington dc a lot of
cia big big school of international
services huge right a very cute probably
the biggest breeding ground for cia
agents and also during world war one the
mckinley building is where they uh
invented chemical warfare for world war
one in the mckinley building oh wow yes
i have cancer from having clouds now a
lot of it's mit
yeah because well nsa is at mit right
but a lot of those um
cia recruits out of um what should we
call it my school is hilarious a lot of
dc schools georgetown whatever just some
like some rich kids from new york and
then you'd have school of vendors it's
just some
just some uh prince's son in a purple
lamborghini studying sociology we have
that in la except they're not in school
right it's a prince's son and a
lamborghini right studying [ __ ] tick
tock or whatever yes you know yeah
royalty has really gone downhill huh
yeah i mean when you look at harry and
megan
how disgusting they have really can you
imagine shame the royal name well it's
just the idea of it's such a hatched
plot yeah first of all him marrying
outside his gene pool was a no-no well
he should have got excommunicated for
that we have a cousin for you lined up
right we have someone that we we share
yeah i feel like the royal babies they
throw the first three out just because
they get born deformed and then meghan
markle who's a hollywood actress and she
she knew they were really she was a big
one before that well no not really being
sarcastic
[Laughter]
she went over there and she took him
another in uh you know america and but
it's just
it's such so clearly a plotted thing in
my opinion you think so come on i
thought i think it's love
well no not only is it not love but it's
she knew they were racist they're the
royal [ __ ] family right
they have the blood of everybody on
their hands and then not only were they
racist but they're so they have to move
to l.a and live in a mansion and get a
deal with netflix
yeah as a way to curate by the way they
moved to america the like
the the country with no racism right
no racism here right no
they moved last summer remember last
summer yeah just everything just calm
and peaceful on the race front yeah
so it's a lot it's a [ __ ] thing
right
well-deserved deal though no i respect
them yes you have to i respect but
that's what roy like everything now is
just
it's just be
famous
to whatever degree you can even though
he was already famous
and appear to be good but they kicked it
up a level they did they went counter
culture on the royal family they did
they went they went counter well it's a
great narrative yes it's a great story
the only thing anyone cares about is
whether the story is good right and it's
a great story right no she moves into
what is it buckingham palace yes they
live happily ever after
you know the queen talks behind their
back all the time you know right but
they don't say anything because they
just they love the queen and they
understand she's old that's not that's
not going to sell papers that's not
going to move the needle no and meghan
markle wants to move the needle
they want to be
people who are movers and shakers yeah
in a way that they weren't and couldn't
be
living in that
rainy
hell skate where people just eat fish
pudding yeah and it's like my
grandmother's a racist whose isn't whose
is it what is the year
3056. yeah i mean right yeah who's is it
who's grandma's super progressive yeah
how's your story unique right you know
but she got a deal at netflix no it's
smart yeah yeah it's smart good for her
what else do we have going on here
uh in the news ben ben's new job now is
he uh recently he gets a hundred
articles and none of them are queued up
for the show i got him right here oh oh
i won't look at me being wrong
lamar cisd teacher remains on leave
following viral rant about the students
what did they say here i'll play it for
you right here
wait a
minute high school leave a week after
she was caught on camera ranting about
her students something that continues to
get a lot of attention from parents and
others but some say this may be a sign
of the stress many educators find
themselves under jason miles has this
story lamar consolidated's harry wright
junior high school has been open for
less than a year and a first-year
teacher recently told students she's had
enough if i have to keep dealing with
kids that are complete and utter morons
i'm done in a video originally sent to
me by a parent and extensively shared on
social media the unnamed teacher is
heard complaining about students and
venting about the job good i want to be
fired at this point i literally am going
to hurt myself if i have to keep coming
here
she adds she wouldn't help students if
they were in need
i have never in my life dealt with kids
that are so awful
that if they fell into a river i would
let them put away she's blown off such
time many parents and others have
reacted to the teacher's rant with
opinions ranging from outrage to
sympathy it's ridiculous i really really
like if she didn't
like what she does i mean why even be a
teacher we
should never
you know
be at a place where we let um you know
let our personal feelings get to that
point particularly in front of kids oh
he's never taken this american
federation
doesn't know the teacher in question
personally but says many have suffered
emotionally amid the pandemic and
related challenges
right now it's it's a time for grace uh
you know it does sound like she needs to
exit out and take a break
in a statement lamar consolidated said
quote parents trust us with their
students every day and unfortunately the
actions of a single person have the
potential to breach that trust the
district called the comments disturbing
and said the teacher is on
administrative leave pending the outcome
of an investigation adding what she said
is not a reflection of the campus as a
whole and it's hard-working staff
in richmond jason miles k-h-o-u
i'm horrified somebody recorded hurts
blowing off some steam also
it's her opinion it's an opinion she's
blown off some steam it's an opinion
it's like if you recorded me saying
something about my wife i love my wife
but once in a while you gotta you gotta
you gotta yell it at this guy to get it
out yeah yeah i mean
you know she's dealing with dumb kids
all day give her a break i mean
the other thing is like it's not china
where she's impressed constantly by
their acumen yeah
these are dumb kids they're dumb
american dumb texas kids yes right yes
they all walk in it would be shocking if
she was like
you know teaching
chinese kids who could play the violin
and she said that but this is that's
more of an accurate report that's every
teacher in america says that my friends
are all like their wives are teachers a
lot of them are like yeah the kids are
horrible yeah they're dumb the parents
are dumb and yeah if they fell into a
river i wouldn't care like yeah that's
every teacher as forever
has always been like that it is not
shocking at all yes and then that
[ __ ] phony going up like
tossing chef capo yeah i think zev capo
said anything untoward he had a [ __ ]
goatee yeah he's like we should never
let our emotions get to that point yeah
goatee's kind of coming at the end on
the topic of jews
yeah someone's name's zeph what is this
man and then he also says it's a time
for grace anyone who mentions god or
grace it's time for grace it's time to
check their credit card statements to
see how many motels right we're in there
yeah there's a lot of grace yeah there's
good
yeah he's in there
he uses the motels what do you call him
a stabbing cabin well you know what it
is let's get up let's get up some of
these videos here
of uh
what i love about austin is that it's
relaxed people are relaxed they want to
enjoy their lives it's not like
california it's a place where people are
peaceful
and it's that peace that makes me feel
at peace and i like it i think it's got
a great vibrant downtown area where
people respect each other
and that's the most important thing for
me it's a cerebral town too yeah people
are thinking and so to me what's good
about it is the absolute lack of
uh you know problems that other major
metropolitan areas have you just don't
have to deal with the things you have to
deal with in la and new york you feel
safe all the time you always feel safe
in downtown austin it's exciting and fun
nobody's getting pushed into subway
tracks there yeah it's you know what it
is it's just people getting together to
enjoy just the great state of texas and
that to me is the most important thing
it's a family place for different people
that really enjoy each other
that's what i like about it they figured
it out somehow texas figured it out
figured it out to have a place without
any crime family-friendly families
walking down the street at night
families love it you feel safe all the
time there's no crime so to me
there's something about it that i just
really enjoy i was there and i was like
i was shocked to see full families
generations walking down the street 10
11 o'clock window shopping going into
some clubs just enjoying the night it
really is something that it's a blessing
i mean the the beauty of people just
kind of getting together and enjoying
each other
to me
is something we've lost in our society
the conversations you can have with
strangers on the street it's something
they're so friendly i i i've experienced
nothing but friendliness and there's
there's a beauty
to when people get together and really
just
celebrate the act of being alive it
feels like a peaceful music festival
every night that's what austin texas is
to me it's it's love it's people
that are expressing love
giannis papa's your podcast is on
substance it's on substance right now
[Laughter]
i just moved it from rockfin
yeah yeah yeah no it's on patreon it's
on patreon patreon.com slash yanni long
days but you know it's on youtube long
days with janice pappas on youtube
spotify wherever you like to listen to
it yeah yeah and it's uh subscribe to
youtube because we just you know you
just got flagged i got flagged and
you've got to slag for youtube and then
joe rogan helped you out he came to my
defense thank you joe i appreciate it
but yeah they flagged me for some
nonsense because you said stuff about
gays i said some stuff about the gays
you said that the gay gay
people should be kept inside i said they
should be locked inside well wha what
was the quote cause this is interesting
the quote was they should all
be
dead no now now my channel
is gonna get [ __ ] i'm kidding of
course what i said was
i said
almost an exact quote i said we support
gay rights but could we please move the
gay parade tonight so i could explain
gay rights to my daughter without having
to see your [ __ ] before 12 noon right
fun joke yeah and you were
you were
given a strike i was given a strike and
but then they rescinded something they
gave you two strikes you got one off
yeah that joe i retweeted like a bunch
of gay people saying like
uh it's hilarious i'm a bear and i think
it's funny one gay guy goes it's
actually a good point
and no one cared and then of course
rogan's thing almost went to a million
views on twitter and then another person
named lucy reached out from youtube and
said we over corrected so we're bringing
your episode back and then i went
further and i said well now tell me
about the other episode cause they took
down two episodes they took down two
full episodes and then the other one i
was talking about
uh just justin bieber's n-word video and
did they say anything about that
they haven't responded yet that one's so
you just have to keep fighting i think
you got to keep fighting i don't know or
you gotta know rogan
both
both one probably is much more important
than the other yeah because they see
that i guess with him it gets some reach
and may turn some people against them
yeah well i think it just doesn't make
sense
they don't make themselves look good
when they do that you know no because
they're taking things ripping them out
of context yeah and they have a platform
where a lot of people say
a lot of different things right and
people make money doing that and you
know it's you know yeah yeah this is
what are we web
2.9 or web 2 but i'm web3 i'm just just
tokenize it you're tokenizing i'm just
in the tokens right now i don't really
give a [ __ ] about web 2. right that's
for you [ __ ] old well i'm going to
sub stack and i'm going to transcribe
stack is web 4. yeah i'm going to read
myself it's free
it's free everything's free over there
web 4. i'm just going to stand there and
read it yeah prior lake minnesota mystic
lake casino this saturday phoenix
arizona stand up live come see me
thursday friday saturday
in february the 10th through the 12th
tampa florida tampa theater thursday
february 17th friday february 8th
orlando florida sunday february 10th san
antonio february 23rd portland maine
come please tickets aren't selling
because every man there has a vagina
providence rhode island thursday
february 24th toronto ontario they're
moving it from february to march because
you're still not [ __ ] open
albany new york at the egg that'll be
fun to 26 concord new hampshire february
27th
um and that's it and then we've got a
few dates being announced in march
including the ryman in nashville very
excited about that shooting especially
march and then done done with the tour
off the road leave me alone four or five
months internet only
[Laughter]
or come to austin or l.a
to see me live because when i'm on the
road off the road it'll be i'll pop in
new york l.a and austin
internet only
i love it
i'm gonna find the professor and i'm
gonna break them
yeah i gotta break it professor who's
the hot new prospect who's the hot new i
think it's eric von schlossberg i love
it yeah from
from
dimitri junior college
in from brookdale yeah from brookdale
community college from the university of
plattsburgh yeah
from saint mary's yeah maria's
um
anything else where are you gonna be
live on the road people come see you yes
i got uh some dates on my website uh the
rooms are a little smaller but intimate
intimate and nice yeah it's nice come
see me february 4th if you if you'd
loved if you want to i'd love it if you
come see me uh february 5th at seoul
joel's right in jeffersonville
pennsylvania then side splitters in
tampa february 10th edmonton alberta uh
february 17th and the 19th comic strip
february 24th through the 26th in new
westminster british columbia and
bloomington minnesota march 3rd to the
5th lol comedy club san antonio march
24th to the 26th house of comedy phoenix
april 14th to the 16th
and giannispava's comedy.com thank you
for coming on thank you dude as always
and uh folks we will be
back next week
we're gonna do you think we're good do
you think we'd go back to saturday night
yeah we could switch back to saturday uh
especially probably gonna go back to
saturdays the tours winding down like
i think that's gonna be the move i've
never liked monday
we're gonna go back to saturday night
and then um
even though the views aren't really hurt
no not at all but you know i think we'll
go back maybe we won't but i think we
will
you can always watch me as a lead in
then if you move back to saturday i'm
saturday early in the day yeah saturday
night we were midnight and everybody
listened to it on sunday yeah and it was
i think that was good i don't know i do
2 p.m usually on saturday yeah we were
releasing saturday what 12 a.m eastern
right ben that's right 12 a.m eastern
late late show
opposite snl
tim dylancomedy.com if you have any
tickets or any questions find all of my
content now and forever
exclusively
[Music]
on
subscribe
[Laughter]